hueles muy bien es casi un olor femenino
como el gel de baño de mi madre huele
como a flores nueve versos uno cita a
ciegas con nueve chicos edición de los
cinco sentidos le pedimos a ghana que
tenga una cita con nueve chicos
basándose sólo en sus sentidos sin poder
verlos cuál de tus cinco sentidos es más
sensible tendría que decir que el oído
es muy importante para mí sé que alguien
es atractivo o no por cómo se escucha
estás nerviosa estoy un poco nerviosa sí
perfecto
chicos están listos por favor pasen
ah
y
[Música]
ronda 1 sentido del olfato anna
utilizará un sentido en cada ronda para
determinar su atracción por cada chico
qué tan sensible estor fatto la verdad
no tengo un gran sentido del olfato es
posible que olfatea profundidad como un
perro
hueles como mi hermano así que es algo
raro
me recuerda a una tienda de descuento
pero no en el mal sentido
hueles muy bien o el examen está color
es interesante es definitivamente
interesante hueles muy bien es casi un
olor femenino como el gel de baño de mi
madre huele como a flores
es como una vela de bath and body works
pero no puedo precisar de qué tipo
tú literalmente no vuelves a nada y eso
me parece muy raro
me hace sentir más cómoda que se ría
mientras lo es menos raro olor a pino
más bien un olor natural pero eso no me
gusta no es un olor fuerte potente
ronda 1 eliminación ana debe elegir dos
chicos para eliminarlos de la cita a
ciegas voy a eliminar al número 7 porque
no puedo leer nada de él
bueno ni modo no puedo ponerme nervioso
por las preferencias nasales de alguien
el 5
me han dicho muchas cosas pero cuando
alguien te dice hueles como mi madre
sería algo raro si no te eliminaron
ronda 2 sentido del tacto
es tan raro eres una persona a la que le
gusta tocar yo diría que todo depende de
la persona así que eso determinaría si
puedo tocar la valla es alto bien
ok es una barba
lo siento tiene una piel muy suave vaya
que es lo que usas qué es esto es
cabello o son los dreadlocks baya son
geniales y una ligera barba cabello
rizado creo que tenemos una pequeña
lista no hay nada fuera de lo común y se
siente como una persona en realidad no
sé lo que estoy buscando ronda 2
eliminación
anna debe elegir dos trucos para
eliminarlos de la ciudad a ciegas
muy bien voy a eliminar al 12 al 5
creo que dijo que olía a tienda de
descuento algo sin igual pensé que los
regalos iban a ser la fuente de dinero
amigo pensé que lo lograría
lo siento
ronda 3 sentido del oído hay algún tipo
de voz que encuentres atractiva quizás
si suenan un poco más alegres porque así
es como suena mi voz hola me llamo
justin y te gusta el jazz no me esperaba
eso hola soy deivid y da motus tatuajes
gracias hola me encantan tus uñas muchas
gracias
espera dijiste tu nombre y tartus muy
bien hola soy justin y quieres salir más
tarde lo preguntas hola ana mi nombre es
george y creo que tu color de cabello te
queda muy bien
gracias estoy notando una sencillo y
observa lineal
un placer conocerte ronda 3 eliminación
muy bien
voy a eliminar david cyrus y justin
número 2
los demás eran mejores no tal vez no son
tan seguro como los demás me sorprendió
un poco porque pensé que lo había hecho
muy bien
estaba pensando que mi frase para
conquistarla debió ser yo soy el de la
piel suave
cómo te sientes sana me siento mucho más
nerviosa ahora que antes
[Risas]
ronda 4 sentido del gusto por dios
muy bien listos 321 ahora
posición de equivocada para besar
muy bien
321 ahora
y más
gracias dios
entonces sana qué piensas del beso de
justin estaba temblando y no pudimos
besarnos bien la primera vez de hecho
fue lindo y cómo fue el beso de ellos
pienso que se sintió más natural y más
cómodo entonces de los dos a quién
quieres elegir como chico ideal
las dos muy bien que te hizo elegir a
ellos el acento me pareció muy dulce
sobre todo con el beso fue muy natural y
muy cómodo estás listo para verlo claro
que estoy lista para quitarme esta
máscara y verlo eso creo rondó final
sentido de la vista yo ya está delante
de ti si puedes quitarte la venda de los
ojos 3 2 1
hola soy george mucho es un placer
conocerte soy yo vaya tienes unos ojos
increíbles por dios
alguna vez has besado a personas
extrañas es probable que haya besado
algunas extrañas pero ninguna venda una
bandada si por turno no te gustaría
tener una cita con él me gustaría creo
que me di cuenta de que no tengo un
estereotipo de persona que me guste
puede que al inicio vea esa persona en
la calle y no me atraiga pero después al
o leerla a tocarla y escuchar su voz
puede que me atraiga mucho más pensé que
iba a ser eliminado en la primera ronda
para ser honesto tengo muy mal olor
corporal pero creo que ahora está bien
si huelo neutral es un buen día para mí
fuiste uno de los finalistas sí cómo fue
bueno ese fue mi primer beso así que sí
por eso estaba tan nervioso o por dios
de verdad eso fue realmente dulce fue
muy lindo que lo hiciera dios mío qué
tal fue el primer beso
es decir no tengo peso para eliminar
para pasarme pero te puedo decir fue
bastante bueno ahora estará en internet
para siempre 3 2 1 muy bien gracias
chicos
eso han hecho entonces qué les pareció
el vídeo es un poco raro o tal vez
interesante bueno si les gustó dejen sus
comentarios aquí abajo suscríbase a
nuestro canal porque tenemos muchas
cosas geniales nos vemos en la próxima
marco polo
marco polo jubilee vive intensamente